uh mr. gose asks you John fund if voter
fraud is as rampant as you believe why
didn't the Bush administration uncover
more evidence of it over their five-year
investigation because the Constitution
gives the power to control elections to
the states and the counties there are
3,000 and 31 counties in America almost
all voter fraud prosecutions are at the
county level the federal government is
almost nothing to do with them except
like Chicago they did where the
questionnaire EC was so vast there were
a hundred thousand fraudulent votes that
were proven and that's the Department of
Justice issue so y know that one what
the vast majority of prosecution of
administration did do a study and they
didn't find anything no yeah I know the
studies show state and federal
prosecutions
there are a lot at the county level and
especially I agree look absentee ballot
fraud is a lot worse than impersonation
fraud but we will never know in the
Supreme Court and the court of appeals
have said this we will never know how
much there is until we actually take
steps to see let me ask you a related
question mr. this could happen this year
what if Romney won the one the popular
vote and Obama won the election like
everyone it wouldn't be that I know Tom
he's it just right but don't you think
it would it would it since it would be
like the fifth time it's happened in
American history don't you think it
would be a good prompting to get rid of
the stupid Electoral College camp
the only way to do it can't deal with
the constitutional states and their
growth stage that can block that
thirteen states actually that can block
this thirteen smaller states would
always oppose it you can't get it done
you might as well move on to something
that you actually can get done on that
point on that point I agree with him
see ya in I action that's a shame
because it's a real [ __ ] up system
about the voter ID I as again a republic
I think we should pay for those voter
IDs there's no question they can free
the Supreme Court said that make him
free gamble my I'm from Macon free
they're free I'm winning okay let's get
it to the offering okay
bara somebody asks you what was it about
Mitt Romney that made you so certain he
would be the GOP nominee a year ago I
knew it two years ago I kept you know if
you look at the history of GOP elections
going back to 76 right the second in
line yep Oh usually when there was one
there was one exception to that and the
reason it is isn't because the voters
get familiar with you it's the backers
people people the backers last time
around they maybe chose Mitt Romney but
Brock a birth MIT Romney they chose
McCain but Mitt Romney lobbied him
really hard
so Romney Lobby those people hard and
they said you know what last time I know
a core what McCain yeah because McCain
lobbied us hard in 2000 sometimes it
takes eight years the car goes we want
Reagan Ford then I went Reagan HW then
it was HW and then you had George W and
McKay was behind us a Democrat like that
Hillary's gonna be the nominee the other
hand right I would eat old people like
Herman Cain and Michelle Bachman have
anything to do with it I was a little a
total incompetent if anybody everybody
else seems like it had to play a role we
also had
with a condor candidate right we have a
poll it was a compound for Newt Gingrich
Daniel water had a lot of baggage this
is not only not only there's a lot of
lonely that think it was he was gonna be
the candidate a year ago I thought it
was the best candidate actually started
out supporting polenta early on
Oh nine but they lent Tim Pawlenty yes
as the time went on out of the food he's
a man wait
polenta yeah that's what I said polenta
I'm Russian we let it go
and and but then as time went on you
looked at all the candidates I think
Romney definitely was the best one and
he's proving it right he's eighteen days
out it's close its close but it was
always gonna be close I mean the
Republican answers the economy is in the
tank not because the well that's first
of all it's not in the tank
we polarize electricity always gonna
work because Romney has such an
incredibly high [ __ ] lead in the
American South because this map today
looks almost exactly like the post-civil
war map we're going in the Middle East
there's a Lisa looks like the 1990 okay
but there's at least twenty five states
where no matter who the Republican was
it doesn't matter what could be the
candidate in Saturday with vote fresh
actually use the commies North you know
what it was North Carolina no cars on
the south and south of mason-dixon line
absolutely mr. I was going to win it
North Carolina winter Obama lies there's
an outright flat all right that was
saying that there are certainly
they're gonna go right but I was new you
all day no but this us ha Wyoming I
could name all the sudden the can all
the slaves also initial well you look
what it what it is old
go left and and that was this very in
that was the very same map and this is
the same Goldwater coalition the strong
together the American South with the
outlaw shall our West peace and that's
how it works
our water got destroyed in 1964 yeah
Mitt Romney's gonna get a little bubble
coming here cannot the older he is not
gonna get destroyed no I do if you know
anything he's gonna get this quick
people anything in the world happens MIT
Romney may win the popular vote because
of the high turnout the what happens but
yeah yes I've destroyed actually I
actually have with the met but when I
say destroyed I mean the electoral
college I mean I think Barack Obama's
gonna hit 300 electoral votes I believe
if you're smoking to be that no it was
war I think he's going to I think is
gonna take Ohio I think he's gonna take
Wisconsin I think he's gonna take Iowa
and that means game okay you're actually
wrong
and if you believe I'm like Mitt Romney
I'm extra time yeah well you know that's
what little performance Nevada that for
alma mater
Colorado North Carolina and Virginia and
loses all the ones you said plus tax on
New Hampshire where she's even in Romney
wins you won't take all around say that
again if he wins which one if you win
North Carolina we should probably work
yeah Virginia richer looks good in right
Colorado
looks good Nevada looks good and your
hampshire looks good and for that he
would he could lose Ohio he wins over
hot it's so probably like this is exam
actually he could run possible I look at
the map he girl is here because he could
run that up so he can run that entire
aboard in stupid that he could Det that
wait a second
that is very possible what he just said
I don't know if it's true cuz I haven't
looked at the map but I'll take your
word for it and they always say if you
don't win Ohio as a Republican you can't
win but you're saying did you know
delusional high because you also have an
Iowan play you have Wisconsin sylvania
because remember Obama do air and so
Pennsylvania had no Romney hadn't
because Susquehanna poll which which was
the best predictor of the 2008 numbers
Pennsylvania remember it's Pittsburgh
Philadelphia and Alabama in the middle
right Obama dissed Pennsylvania in 2008
by saying these are filled with towns
the state that were they cling to their
guns and religion but not forgotten that
yeah they have not forgotten factly it's
gonna be really close I cannot believe
you can dispute that it's me really
close and our elections are always by
the way when he said they can we lost my
500 Bhama want to Lance law when he said
they cling to their gun to their
vibration he was so way off
Reagan crossed me today
boy was he wrong about that all right
thank you everybody we gotta go
Pizza Real Time with Bill Maher Friday
night at 10:00 ask Bill at his guests to
have lessons right after the show at
hbo.com